thank you
the prophet Muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a Sim at
the house in Jannah and we know the
great reward that will not only be
gained but rather will fill your grave
after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale
how are you guys doing I came across a
video which is uh quite inspiring
actually from Joe Rogan and he was
speaking about some as he calls them
Islamic fighters in the UFC let's take a
look at the video and then respond to in
kind some of the most disciplined people
that I know are very religious it's
really fascinating it's particularly
Fighters like a lot of the Islamic
Fighters out of Dagestan they're some of
the most dominant Fighters and some of
the most religious Fighters so devout
and because they don't have the
distractions that a lot of the hedonists
do yeah you know they're not party like
the guys at a khabib nurmagmentos camp
or some of the most dominant Fighters
they're they wear their hair all exactly
the same way they practice all they care
about is like family religion training
they they don't chase girls they don't
drink they're just they're they're just
training constantly like insanely
dedicated to their craft and they're the
most dominant khabib is very wealthy
yeah and he drives a Toyota truck I mean
he's uh he lives in the same house I
mean it's like he's very devout in his
beliefs and the way he's raising other
Fighters and now he just got out I think
he's decided to retire completely from
Mexico large coaching and everything
very religious so I think that was quite
interesting the way he kind of phrased
that and obviously him being a kind of
color commentator for the UFC or he has
been a color commented vfc for very many
years and MMA enthusiasts he's seen uh
different Fighters with different
backgrounds act in different ways and I
think there is something which is quite
specialized about the behaviors the
dispositions the temperaments and the
prioritizations of the dakasani fires by
Islamic fires in general I think
he hit the nail on the head really Joe
Rogan who I must say on a tangential
Point has really grown in the way he is
speaking about Islam and Muslims from
let's say five or ten years ago where
you'll see on this channel there's many
videos that I put out critical of him
for putting on at least what seemed to
be pejorative content about Islam and
Muslims now he's I think grown in his uh
thinking towards Islam and Muslims but
having said that some of the things that
he said are staple Parts the Muslim diet
if you like I mean obviously he mentions
Faith and family and these are the
priorities of every Muslim faith of
course believing in one God worthy of
worship that is the essence of Islam and
family and then to take care of your
family to take care of your children to
take care of your community and there is
a very strong communitarian ethic
attached to the religion of Islam
especially vis-a-vis one's own family in
the house very really direct quotations
from the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
peace and blessings be upon Him relating
to how to take care of your family for
example every Shepherd is responsible
for his flock
and that the man is responsible for his
family and that the woman is responsible
for her family as well so in a way when
the man is not present the woman becomes
if you like the leader of the family to
to raise the children to do these things
so there's a strong family ethic in
Islam obviously from a spiritual
perspective the Quran says
that protect yourselves and your
families from the Hellfire which of
course is something we believe in heaven
and hell so yes this is something very
Central and to be honest with you it
filters away as he mentions quite
accurately I would say the distractions
that people have in life especially in
the age of distraction we are in the age
of distraction with our smartphones
people watching five to ten hours of
television and smartphone stuff and
having screen times which are actually
verging on the comical
because they are no longer in control of
their lives but they have become a slave
to the algorithm itself
and so in this age having priorities and
having goals and having
a hierarchy of if you like needs that
you identify yourself is of the utmost
important importance and not being
swayed by things like Fame the opposite
gender and riches and so on is something
that someone has to temper and tether
within their own psychological or
psychopsychological disposition I'm
happy that he was able to identify these
points and hopefully he'll be able to
identify more of these points in the
future
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more